good afternoon thanks so much for
joining us at four i'm kirsten joyce
and i'm christian costa as well once
again we are rooting on our golden
knights like there was never any doubt
right all right
well the team is back home looking to
take a step closer to reaching
the stanley cup final sports director
chris matthews leads off our golden
knights coverage
from the fortress tonight hey chris
how you doing guys i'll tell you what
all the talk of course in las vegas was
hey is it going to be robin leonard mark
andre fleury in that
of course after game four it was peter
deboer who was saying that he just gave
fleury a rest in game four
and he would go back to fleury well that
looks like it's going to happen here
tonight because
marc-andre fleury first off the ice it
was leonard who hung
around for some extra work so looks like
tonight that mark andreith fleury the
36-year-old will get to start here in
game five a very important game
might mention the knights and the
canadians both traded overtime wins
up there in montreal vegas looking for a
fast start montreal looking for a fast
start and a win here in game five going
to be a big one
for both teams now the suit is all tied
at two games a beast
also what the vegas gold knights are
looking for is some offense from its
forwards just three goals scored
by the forwards in this entire series of
course the buzz up in montreal right now
is all about that
game four and vegas not getting whistled
for as many penalties as often as
montreal
because actually there is a big
discrepancy but according tonight's head
coach peter deboer
there is a reason for that you know the
whole
power play penalties narrative that's
that's coming out you know i i'm i'm not
i'm not buying that i mean we were the
one of the least penalized teams in the
league during the regular season the
montreal was one of the most
so you know if there's a disparity there
because
uh they're they're calling it looser or
tighter
i think that disparity uh you know
is the same as as it was during the
regular season that's what that's what
we both
are all right
and i'll tell you what else is happening
inside the fortress it's loud right now
as they get set for this huge game but
now let's toss it outside
where kevin martin has been tracking
down some fans there on toshiba plaza
and kevin i'll tell you what
fans are thrilled about game five
whoever wins this one takes a huge step
toward reaching that stanley cup final
well yeah thanks chris and exactly with
the series tied at two games at piece
it all comes down to a best of three of
course
game five here tonight at the fortress
and as you mentioned golden knights fans
are starting to file in didn't take me
long to find
two huge ones renee and tammy renee
starting with you have you recovered
from the thrilling game four and
how are you feeling heading into game
five i'm feeling really excited
and i'm still kind of in shock about
game four
watching panda he was amazing
he proved everybody wrong he's got it
so i was i'm excited i love it and it
looks like fleury will get the start
tonight he was the first goalie off the
ice at morning skate
you guys will be in there for game five
what are you expecting the atmosphere to
be like
electric magic just magic in there i
love it i love it and
can we get some predictions what are you
predicting the final score of renee
game five here tonight uh four to two
we're going to win
two i like it what about you i'm taking
the win but i'm too superstitious to
throw it out of number
okay born on the 13th and i will not bet
awesome before i let you go check out
their outfits they got the ears
they have the victory flamingo she even
has the purse i mean
they are decked out here for game five
and the bracelets
of course we'll continue the coverage
all the way up to puck drop at six
o'clock reporting live outside of
t-mobile arena kevin martin eight sports
now all right kevin
thank you so much we'll check back with
you a little bit later